good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast
happy friday and it is friday we're
ringing in friday with a first-time
co-host
hannah berner hello hannah berner it is
such an honor and a privilege i've
manifested this and we've made it happen
oh my god well it's friday and we do a
little thing here on friday that i
hopefully you can join me okay ready i
think you'll know it when you hear it
friday friday gotta get down
thank you that was stunning thank you so
much for doing that welcome and now i'm
awake yes first time co-host guest
hannah berner thank you so much for
being here well i've been that like
outskirt friend where you're like so
tight with taylor schrecker darren carp
and i'm friends with them and i'm like
so
how do i join like the friend group and
they're like don't force it or like
don't force it if you force it she'll
hate you and i was like okay i'm just
gonna sit and manifest with my crystals
well we do have to say how this was the
second time trying to get you on the
show yeah the first time you you guys
did like back out on us it you know what
it was one of those um out of your
control moments out of control moments
that i did cry about
paige and i dig in and fight about paige
and i were gonna come on together yeah
and it was like whatever it was like a
thing with the network yeah yeah yeah
it's like a thing um so thank you so
much for being here i know you're like
super busy but i know that you are pop
culture girly and i'm excited to just
sit down talk chat fellow female
comedian to another like you know it's
so hard out there for us just so hard of
this male dominated industry that we're
just taking over um i do have to say
that i did put on these nails for you
however i feel like i took women back
like 10 years with these
okay here's the thing i love press-on
nails like i'm a one thing about me is
that i'm a press-on nail girl she's a
girly i don't have nails right now and
like i probably will tomorrow and they
will be press-on um but it's an art
because i just tried to poop before the
show and i couldn't wipe my own [ __ ]
yeah and i'm like how am i gonna take
down the patriarchy without the ability
to wipe your own ass to use your fingers
no that's
that's we didn't think about this i mean
could i stab a [ __ ] absolutely
yes but probably not because those
aren't really glued on very well one
fell off like right before you sat down
so if you tried to stab someone like
your nail would probably just i was like
do you love and she's like get your fake
nails off the floor
it's okay our carpet here is like a
cesspool of disaster now there's just
one of your nails floating around in it
and it's very own brand it's like you
know it's just carpets are great because
they just eat it up soak it up it's a
part of toast history now
you know i love that also i wanted to
let you know that
i have a common story with you and
teresa giudice oh because i used to work
for batches as an interviewer no i
didn't know that back in the day i know
this story like like kind of but go say
it so yeah i
i was confident because i'm half italian
half jewish and i was like i didn't
watch real housewives of new jersey and
i just was like i know this woman's name
mm-hmm and i get up and i'm so cocky and
confident and i'm like teresa guidi jay
and she goes
what'd you call me that's not my name
yeah and i'm so embarrassed we get over
it i i've seen that video by the way and
it's one of the best things on the
internet like i highly recommend
everyone go find it
and i love that i like kept it in
because i edit it and i was like she
deserves to tell the people the truth no
it's an honest moment thank you fast
forward yeah i see teresa on the street
she's like wearing a gown doing
something important and we make eye
contact and i could tell she knows who i
am and i'm like oh my god teresa loves
me and i'm like hi and she goes girl
with no job
and i'm like i deserve that we're one
for one we're one for one i went for it
like i just went with it because i'm not
gonna tell teresa she's wrong honestly
though like the fact that theresa knows
girl with no job she's been on the
podcast but like she does a million
things she's like literally the busiest
woman alive the fact that she knows girl
no job like i'm sorry that happened to
you but for me no i was like yes i do
have a huge social following in a book
and a husband and i'm hilarious thank
you and i always have a husband almost
can i ask you a question like i'm if
there's one thing about me i'm a press
on now girly but i'm also like a huge
internet sleuth like beyond like i read
everything it's like just like i'm the
worst type of person on the planet um
and a couple weeks ago like there was
like a lot of theories that you were not
engaged anymore did you know that yes
100 but then you were like posting your
regular life and like you were still
engaged yeah i was actually on a ski
trip with dez and my phone fell in the
snow
crying screaming like that's a typical
yes if you're not crying during your ski
trip did you even ski so i went to the
verizon store and i'm like waiting to
fix my phone which you know is a
nightmare awful and then my phone's
blowing up and people are like are you
okay and i'm like honestly no my phone
is [ __ ]
and they're like no are you guys still
together and i think it's because we
haven't
i'm not i don't like post him a lot
recently especially after being on a
reality show with him for a second
and i think people assume if you're not
like always posting a relationship that
you guys hate each other yeah but i'm
trying to normalize that like you don't
have to prove that you love your person
i couldn't agree more like normalize
keeping like important things in your
life private yeah and i think also he's
the kind of guy that
doesn't really like promoting his
relationship like that was never his
life he's been single like
he's 46 right he's exhausted he's tired
he doesn't want to do photo shoots and
we respect that for him and loki i kind
of like being like
he's the least interesting thing about
me i i actually i feel that for you i do
i'm trying i'm like i'm trying to
decenter men from our lives which is
hard because i i'm obsessed yeah and
we're obsessed with our men
but i do think that was kind of the root
of it that people like went with it
because they're like she hasn't posted
about him in three months right i knew
and then i was thinking i'm like oh my
god i haven't seen him on her instagram
i'm like oh no like maybe they did break
up and i recently did a tick talk about
like that couple that post three
paragraphs i'm like the longer the
caption the shorter the relationship i
have to say when you're posting on
instagram think about the motive why are
you posting why do you want to tell it
also if you're talking about ups and
downs before you even got married like
what are we doing i couldn't agree more
and like i'm not trying to fight with
anyone i'm just saying
instead of trying to get the world to
think your relationship is awesome work
on
trying to actually make your
relationship awesome and then also no
relationship is the fairy tale that
people are posting on instagram that's
why when
celebrities break up everyone's like i
don't believe in love and it's like no
the love you were seeing was not what it
actually was right no and like people
break up all the time and it just
validates love like it's
empowering we love a breakup moment so
you're a bride
okay i also did watch your say yesterday
girl girl no one's judging your reality
tv moment no one is judging it's true no
one is judging
[ __ ]
no one is judging i just have to say i
loved your dress i know it wasn't the
one you chose because
yeah but because i tried to go back i
obviously wasn't gonna like pick a dress
on camera like that's just crazy to me i
can't explain it like yeah so i said yes
and i was like let me come back for this
dress do alterations like bring more
people see if i really like it and when
i came back there like the dress is gone
i'm like okay like it wasn't meant to be
i wasn't like that in love with it and
then i tried on a bunch of other dresses
i'm like [ __ ] i really needed that
initial dress but the silhouette was
right the silhouette was right it was
really beautiful um overall a negative
experience
would i do it again no
would i recommend to a friend who's
getting married no i do think though
like you had to you had to of course i
loved watching say yes to the dress when
i saw you on it i saw that like you were
totally having fun with it your sisters
were so cute on it it's this is the
thing with reality tv it's context yeah
it's context context context right me
and the girl whose house flooded in
louisiana like how was that fair a
thousand percent how is that fair and
but i do think that seeing you so
excited also seeing you as a young
successful woman who also
has this great career that you're not
like what is he gonna let me spend for
the dress right i liked that no i'm like
[ __ ] i'm paying for it yeah it was
empowering um well thank you so much for
bringing that up i can't wait to bring
up some of your embarrassing moments if
that's okay because the second i said it
i was like oh no no because in my head
it was a fun experience for me no and
you know what like at the time i was so
excited about it like i love to say yes
to the dress i haven't really watched a
single episode since mine because i'm
just like so scarred from the experience
you're like how dare you come on my show
and
you're literally bringing out my trauma
the first time i went on taylor
stricker's radio show who gave me my
first ever radio experience
i'm serious on on actually know her solo
show subscribe download swipe up she um
it was like a three hour show so i came
in like i was about to run a marathon oh
i've done that before her three-hour
shows are so i had a gatorade a banana
and a scone and then at some point the
scone was really dry and um we were
putting it to the face
she got so many messages after they call
it sconegate now they were like never
let that woman with the scone chewing be
on your platform again by the way first
rule of audio broadcasting no food in
sight i've had like big time celebrities
come and chewing gum and i'm like do i
want to fight do i want to start this
it's just i mean
kids are making millions of dollars
doing asmr so i was like taylor maybe i
was ahead of the game yeah maybe but she
had to have a sit down she's like i
think you're funny and i think you have
potential but if you ever walk in my
studio again with a dry scone we're
gonna go and have a fight a scone is a
choice and you chose violence that day
you did
so anyway just shout out to taylor i
love taylor strecker i love you for
being here congrats on your wedding
congrats on all your stand-up success
you're like never in new york now right
you're constantly i'm i'm doing this
thing where i'm i'm going to random
cities and doing my stand up and we call
it like testing different locations and
the girlies are everywhere the girlies
are everywhere and i do think i've
giggly squad with paige i think the
toasters and the giggler is over for
sure
paige and i joke that she's the jackie
and i'm the claudia yeah and i'm not
we're not trying to like say we are the
morning toast because we would never no
because you're globally squad you're
like unique on youtube
we do like the dichotomy 100
where the listeners can be like i'm a
page i'm a hannah so you have a giggly
squad you also have your own podcast i
think that but now that i'm alone and
jackie's obviously you know nurturing a
life alone and scared
naked and afraid
i have been doing some alone podcasts
like especially on our patreon and i
have like the
most respect for people who host solo
podcasts
do you do like a lot of content on your
own and like when you do how the [ __ ] do
you do it like who do you talk to okay
so burning in hell started right before
i began reality tv where i was like i
want people to if they like me be able
to get more of me authentic voice
whatever so i talk to people about their
demons it's a mental health comedy pod
burning in hell
you have to like butter people up then
break them down then bring them back up
that's what i'm doing to you right now
yes i know i'm sweating and
it's it's so much harder than me going
with paige for an hour and just shooting
this [ __ ] so
you're gonna have some guests that like
are are very famous but you've no
chemistry with and you're like i pulled
teeth the whole time and i hate myself
and you design the awkward one and but i
think it's going to make you stronger as
a performer it's just
a lot more work it's so
scary like i just i now i see like i'm
looking in the podcast or people who
have certain podcasts i'm like respect
respect respect for every single one no
it's hard about it you have to listen
so
i have been told like since i was a
child i was always like a very
theatrical
loud annoying some would say
child and people are always like you're
gonna have your own talk show one day
and like for a while growing up i'm like
yeah that's what i want like i want to
have my own talk show and i'll never
forget like the realization i had i'm
like well a talk show is actually mostly
listening to other people like you bring
out guests you bring on experts you
bring on panelists i'm like um actually
no like i want to be the person who goes
on a talk show not vice versa yes i will
edit giggly squad sometimes and hear
things paige said and be like never
heard that in the moment first time
100 because we're just going at each
other and it's so organic and so fun but
yeah you have to listen you have to take
what they say and go deeper and it's
hard and i'm sorry for that however i
think you have a way of bringing a side
of people out oh god thank you um and i
i love that for you i also i'm not
trying to brag but during a very
depressive episode oh my god you talking
tic tac sounds insane
and this is going to be like the most
annoying podcast episode of all time
i've like
has fully gone to my house me too my
whole stand-up bit is like literally me
talking to i love what you want me to do
about that like that's all i do it's so
annoying
i have a tick-tock for us to make after
but anyway yeah during a particularly
depressive episode i read your entire
book
oh wow that must have been really dark
time for you actually
no i just have to say and i'm like
literally licking your [ __ ] right now
but no i love it that book was so
vulnerable oh my gosh so insightful and
i giggled the whole time thank you
because i was going through a really
hard time in my career
so i was like let's see someone who's
actually even though you're younger has
had the most incredible journey yeah and
like
is aspirational to me thank you so i
remember everyone needs to read the book
i read girls no job.com slash book yeah
you really and when i say i don't read
like i can't even get through a long
instagram caption yeah by the way me
neither but that's i think just and i
can barely read so the fact that i got
through it is truly incredible
how long did it take you to write a
while like from january no actually like
seven months not as long as i thought
yeah you don't have that much time like
you have a deadline they're like girl
where's the chapters where the pages
reminds me of vanderpump when staff is
just like sitting there like
but you know what i wanted to say is
that i actually think what you've done
is really interesting and i think it was
actually really smart like i think a lot
of people would have gotten on a show
like summer house and like thought like
you know they're made in the shade i'll
have money for life like i'm sad i don't
have to work ever again but i thought
you did such a good job of like really
branding yourself outside of the show
building other businesses two podcasts
that's like when the time came when like
you were done with the show you
still have so much going on and i think
that's like a mistake a lot of reality
stars it happens to them a lot it's like
you get so comfortable you're making
this money and it's like you seemingly
are just living your life and getting
paid to live your life yeah in 15
minutes of fame you feel like everyone's
always gonna care it's gonna last
forever exactly and i do think the
girlies need to embrace and i hate to
sound like a finance tic-tac right now
but like multiple sources of income
building generational wealth yeah
yeah no you're right we love and i think
where i feel connected to you also is i
kind of started as a meme page too where
i was writing
i was like betcha's boot camp i called
it i was writing like 80 to 100. yeah
you worked for better i know that was my
first start in entertainment
we worked in a wework triggering
i think i've actually been to that
rework yes and i i think i remember you
coming to the office before but i was
just like once
yes
but i was writing so many memes and so
many tweets and writing my own writing
funny videos for them but then i
realized how my voice was different than
their voice and i started writing my own
tweets and like pitching it to meme
accounts i probably pitched you because
i was annoying and but you have to be
you have to be you have to be no
literally being thirsty is like the new
thing and men are not thirsty no they
just
network they're networking men are being
strategic with their centers partners
they call them financial analysts right
no they're just their sponsors so yeah i
started i got like a following of people
who liked my tweets before summer house
and i started my podcast so summer house
to me was like this lucky opportunity
that helped me get more of a platform
and was such a fun experience when i was
single
and drunk and 26. carefree and carefree
and then now
that i now i can really focus on my
stand up which i don't think i would
have had the confidence if i hadn't been
on camera and like learned that i like
to write and be in front of the camera
no i think it's great like i think this
journey for you is really meant to be
but that's why i liked reading your book
because there's so many journeys out
there like how to get into law school or
how to become a reality tv star that's
very like these are the ways you do it
right where you are like chaotic energy
and that is where i
feel you're my comfort you know okay
like that's how there's comfort of the
chaos yes and i think that people who do
their like five year plans it's super
restricting like can't be me we didn't
even you didn't even know tick tock
would blow up right a year ago how could
you say i want to be a buyer like you
are so blown up on tick tock like i need
advice because i there's nothing in the
world that i care more about than tick
tock i will and there's nothing in the
world that tick tock cares less about
than me
and it's very very upsetting it's just
it ain't right honestly well you're on
your i'm in you're in my algorithm yeah
because we follow each other okay so
we're obsessed with each other so i'm
like she's killing it i'll tell you
girlies right now because anyone should
do it i'm posting two to three times a
day right now i know like that's
this is the there's one thing about me
i'm a press on nelly girlie
but i'm also like hands down the laziest
[ __ ] alive like it is amazing like that
i've built a business because you would
die if you knew how lazy i was like
so posting two tick tocks today i'm like
uh no no but you it's you have to think
of it as like a job like you have to
work at it of course also this is going
to sound horrible but quantity over
quality
okay yeah because you cannot be a
perfectionist with your tic tac videos
at all yeah and i also i'm going to tell
you this and this is going to make you
want to do it
you're coming up with stand-up bits all
the time yeah whenever you think of a
premise which is like a concept for an
idea
say it to the camera and come up with a
funny little surprise at the end and
just post it so these are like
bad
jokes that didn't make the cut of the
show or it's the beginning and then in a
month it's a beautiful joke you're doing
on stage for thousands of people that's
actually an interesting one so you can
use it as like throwing it's like
tweeting like my tweets are crazy
rehearsal yes okay i see that and people
just want like the funny idea that it's
shareable yeah um and i i see you as a
tick tock princess so do i but like tic
tac doesn't see me at all you need to
bully the [ __ ] out of tick tock and be
like i'm here i'm here but you're doing
it no not me literally thinking i'm
shadow man
because i'm like i'm never going viral
i'm like oh my god tic tac is
suppressing me like the outgoing okay i
just love the video you have to make
this when you get home be like the girl
who thinks she's shadow band even though
her videos are just bad and they have
little cuts of being like oh my god they
shadow banded me again and it's
literally me and i'm obsessed with that
for you it's but it's true i'm like i'm
laying in bed with ben i'm like search
me on tick tock do i come up
because also
means like you're low-key important that
you did something
yeah yeah like you're being censored by
the government yeah it's like they had
to stop you you were being so intense
that's just maybe like my grandiose like
like the way i see myself is like more
important than i am but also let's be
honest you have conquered every single
platform this is the universe being like
let's give you a challenge yeah no and
the thing is like i'm not up front
i'm like so defeated i'm like people are
always giving me tips like remy bader
was on and i'm like give me tips and she
was giving me like really good [ __ ] it
was like take clothes and [ __ ] on and i
was just like i was like hearing her and
i was like no like i'm not well remy
does like full long intensive beautiful
videos right and like she works so hard
at it she works so hard and we love that
for her we do we're so supportive but
like when it came to her advice i'm like
i'm hearing you
but i'm not hearing but i'm also
reckless with tick tock like i'll post
four in a row at midnight
oh like i'll be right people are like
that's that's not how you don't have a
strategy i have no strategy except keep
pushing forward keep trying
just keep bothering people until they
care yeah yeah if i kind of like this
identity for you and maybe other girls
will connect with the shadow band
princess
should she know my username i think you
should or maybe start a second account
like you know all these famous people
have like a verified account and then
like a fake tick tock account i think
i'm gonna be what was it the shadow band
queen yeah the shadow bank queen yeah i
kind of love that i like that girl and
tic toc the queen of getting banned yes
so i'm gonna be the queen of getting
shadow bands yes i love that for me okay
but you've never been shot at them
before not once no one narry not a
moment no no i'm fully available to be
followed i love how ben four times a day
is like checking yeah and he's like he
wants to be there for me he's like no
baby you're coming up i'm like but maybe
it's because you follow me like go make
another account and then look up see if
i come up i've done that with my manager
i have to say and i'm like you follow me
you don't understand this i'm part of
your algorithm and they're like [ __ ]
you just put up a terrible video no i
know it's like your content is just
horrible
and i'm like oh okay thanks appreciate
it um well i figured it out hannah is
going to join me on today's episode
doing the past five talking all things
you know talking [ __ ] yeah um so i think
we should just jump into it because if
we don't like we will never yeah we need
the momentum
here are the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
peloton peloton is pushing further with
so much new on the peloton bike and the
peloton bike plus they've got new
classes new music and new ways to keep
your workouts fun and motivating gotta
keep things fresh it's the best way to
stay motivated and keep yourself from
burning out and doing the same thing
over and over so they have new artist
series music selections so they're
adding a ton of fun new artists series
classes you can work out to most of the
single artists for the entire class from
your favorite hits to the deep cuts pop
rock hip hop edm there are over 100
artists series to choose from find your
favorite music and turn your next
workout into a concert it's easier to
stick with your goals to when you keep
your workouts interesting peloton has a
workout for every day in every schedule
de-stress from a long day with 30
minutes of strength 20 minutes of cardio
or do a 15 minute total body class
before work stay motivated while having
fun with bike workouts yoga meditation
dance cardio and more visit
onepeleton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by caraway
it's time to ditch the chemicals with
caraway homes non-toxic cookware and
bakeware collections so you can make
healthier cooking a piece of cake their
non-toxic kitchenware are all designed
for the modern home and they feature a
chemical-free ceramic coating so food
can be prepared with peace of mind that
no hard-to-pronounce compound will leach
into your healthy ingredients so it's
super non-toxic really easy to cook
they're naturally slick surface mean
surface means minimal oil or butter for
slide off the pan eggs and easy cleaning
also the colors are stunning every time
they drop a new color it's like fashion
week
highly recommend really stunning visit
caraway home.com toast to take advantage
of this limited time offer for 10 off
your next purchase this deal is
exclusive to our listeners so visit
carawayhome.com
c-a-r-a-w-a-y home dot com toast or use
code toast at checkout caraway non-toxic
cookware made modern all right hannah
are you ready i'm so ready i can't lie i
wish you came out a day where like the
news was popping but you know we do the
show every day and like not every day
can be no we'll make it pop we'll make
it pop so here's some make my [ __ ] pop
yes
okay here's a big nothing burger from
page six
rihanna plays coy when asked about her
diamond quote engagement ring so she's
staying mom on the massive diamond ring
she's been rocking on that finger this
week she said this old ring you act like
you've never seen it before she joked to
the paparazzi in l.a on tuesday when she
asked when she was asked point blank if
she's engaged to boyfriend um asap rocky
so she's wearing a sloan solitaire ring
from bryony raymond and rihanna has
actually sported uh this ring a few
times in the past albeit on a different
finger so she said i feel like that's
the type of mom i'm going to be psycho
oh okay so let's let's talk about two
things first it's like do you think
rihanna's engaged
i think pregnant rihanna
is back in the limelight so hard and
it's so funny to me because she was like
i hate everyone and then she got
pregnant and she's like what do you guys
want yeah
like literally belly for everyone yeah
and then there's a celebrity thing where
they're like i have so many diamonds i
forgot if i'm engaged or not and and
that's like aspirational in a way but
it's also like annoying it's not special
i actually feel bad for them you know
like you have so many diamond rings that
you don't even value one that was given
to you like by someone you love so
dearly like how sad i have sympathy for
you i'm an empath so like i feel sadness
for other people you know and that's how
i feel when i see rihanna like with all
of her engagement rings you know yeah
diamonds are forever as rihanna says
yeah i also think it's i don't think it
was rihanna who said that oh originally
that was ralph waldo emerson no it's
like originally like
like someone like older and then like
re-animated her thing but yeah no i
agree but like
we re made it fun um i i think it's
anyway
we don't do history so she
i feel like celebrities love having
babies before they get married it's
almost like become chooky to get married
i could like the tradition am i getting
married no like i feel like the way like
haley and justin are doing it is like
really chewy
you know like marriage and then like a
couple years baby like very christian
like i think like the way gen z
perceives like cool things now like they
would find that chewy yeah like even
planning a wedding so many times i've
been like is this this is so chewy i
have to tell you that like weddings are
cheap like and even like the most
tasteful the most refined chic
big budget look like
it's it's chewy and it's chewy to
genzies obviously because they can't get
married they're 14. they're just jealous
they're literally 14. they're literally
14. so it's not like in right um but i
feel like rihanna she's having fun with
it but it's interesting to me because
we're all just like put out new music no
she's like nah i think i'll have a baby
i think i'm a baby i think no i think
i'll start a lingerie line i think i'll
start a billion dollar makeup company i
think i'll have a boyfriend i will not
put out music yeah but yeah she's
putting out a new life which obviously
is super important it's super beautiful
yeah we believe in new life here at the
morning time we're we're pro new life
we're probably i'm totally kidding
we're new life new life
but then again the baby is not asking to
be put in this world
which i feel like it's a little selfish
that's a hot take extremely hot takes i
don't know i know yeah like if i had in
this climate if i had known that like i
was gonna have to you know deal with all
this [ __ ] once i got out of the room
i might have second guess if i had known
that i was gonna be shadow band on tic
tac every day of my life would i want to
be here what i have accepted
um i don't think rihanna's engaged i
think she's just rich which is a common
misconception in hollywood
like she's like kylie's always like with
these massive diamond rings and it's
like nope
not engaged it's like one of my six
stylists accidentally put it on the
wrong hand right you only have so many
fingers and i will fire her and put it
on your thumb yeah you really only have
eight or pinky so you really have six
was chloe's massive heart ring an
engagement ring unclear unclear she's
just rich she's just rich but then what
i think you'll enjoy because we were
just talking about teresa
is earlier in the week yeah uh rihanna
was asking what kind of mom she would be
and she said she's going to be psycho
like teresa giudice
we don't love that word we don't love
the word psycho however
i feel like theresa is such a [ __ ]
good mom i think she's like say what you
want about teresa and i have plenty to
say when it comes to housewives she's an
amazing mom theresa is an amazing mom
her daughters are killing it her
daughters are like look at gia
gia is incredible but also melania is
my like queen queen and also like i want
to grow up and become milan don't count
out gabriella don't count out gabriella
because especially in last week's
episode like she will come for you even
if even if you're her mother do you know
why she's dangerous why we would not
understand this she's silent she listens
yeah she's silent like louis says two
ears one mouth listen
and we've never experienced that before
in our lives so we wouldn't know but
that was like a crazy thing for someone
to say
two ears one mouth listen more if my
[ __ ] husband if that ever said that's
me like i'd be like get pack your things
i'd be like one mouth bite your dick off
i'd be like one mouth get the [ __ ] out
pack your things venomous
sweetheart the best you take for granted
a man that is like down to do all the
content with you because the average man
is like absolutely not no can i tell you
actually i really don't take it for
granted i'm like super grateful to ben
every time but also ben
loves it like ben loves being married to
the content queen
because like all these opportunities
like he podcasted with me yesterday and
he's like really popular people love him
as a co-host personally like i hate to
put my marriage on display because
people are like we're like a bickering
type yes and people are always like
honey is so mean tim i'm like no like
have you ever been married like that's
what it's like you're like i don't wanna
pick sides but he deserves it but he
loves it and he gets up yesterday he was
like yesterday's episode it was it was
strong like it was a good one and he
gets up and he's like i feel like i'm
becoming a natural i'm like yes
but i also think that when you're in the
kind of job we are you need a person
who's supportive of it like i don't want
to bring up like talk about other people
but like paige and craig for example i
love this moment for her where she's
with a guy who's fully supportive of her
reality tv career because i've been with
her where like she's dating and it's
hard can i tell you like the bullets i
would take for paige and craig as a
couple like
i
literally like i didn't the two of them
never crossed my mind as even potential
suitors
and now that they're here
like i
i don't think i'm ever going to be the
same honestly and by the way i try to
put it out there like not to put
pressure on them as a couple
if they ever break up like seriously i
will riot i will storm the best steel we
do not want to put pressure on them or
negative energy or negative energy or
any kind of anything but the fun thing
is i will call her to like talk [ __ ]
and he's in on it with her like he's
popping in yeah he's telling me the
drama and i'm like this is you love a
guy who actually cares about the front
drama and if there's one thing about me
i'm press on nail girly mm-hmm because i
haven't been like a craig conover girly
since day one like i have been
i've been here for craig like constantly
and jackie really is is responsible for
that because she's been like a real
southern charm like historian and she
like has always seen the value in craig
and how craig always stood by catherine
and how the whole [ __ ] cast was wrong
about catherine and they all took
thomas's side except craig so not only
is craig a precious gem of a man craig
is a man who supports women and like
just the fact that they these two found
each other like i really can't put them
towards the joy i feel so i just if you
could so with that said when you're
looking for a man find someone who
really does fit into your career because
your career is number one with him right
so it's like for example the fact that
does is also stand up but he's in like
he's 46 he's like lived his life and he
literally is like go work i was selfish
when i was thirty is important yeah
cause you will get animosity towards him
if he starts being like oh you're gonna
do the morning times when we're supposed
to cuddle absolutely not oh my god
that's so lame um also like you having a
man that's much older than you like tell
me about that we love azadi yeah like is
it just nice to be with someone who's
like so wise like has so many years of
wisdom but that's the thing do i hate
that he's lived so much life without me
and do i like use it against him every
day yes that would kill me because like
me and ben met when we were literally
like seven and i'm like well i know you
guys are so pure
what were you doing before me like
literally like it was like my mom was
cutting up my pb j like what do you want
me to do like that kills me so like if
there was more time like i would
literally like kill someone
so i've joked that i have my
bachelorette party coming up it's in
miami we're very excited and i'm like
des what are you gonna do for your
bachelor party oh yeah and he's like my
whole life's been a bachelor party and
i'm like ew and then he goes i'm just
gonna sit down and close my eyes and
remember things and i'm like oh
that's hot but
yeah but he's literally tired he's
exhausted he's not chasing women on the
street he's on the verge of arthritis
but he has like the swag of a guy who's
lived a long life and also there's a lot
of security knowing like he physically
cannot go chase women exactly we love
that he currently just got like a little
hip operation
his lower back i say girls if you want
to find a zaddy you go to walgreens and
you hang out in the advil section
they're all over the place yeah just
like snorting in a leave but i also to
get a little deeper i think that i had a
really tough relationship when i was
like 25 as everyone should
and then i got really kind of blocked
off
and i loved going after these really hot
men who i had no
real emotional
connection
or even like i would tell myself like i
don't respect them like i would never
take them seriously for
a marriage and you really have to
respect how their mind works and respect
the conversation but it was fun for me
to live a little like [ __ ] models
right dumb football guys and then
you eventu that was me
being closed off
because i knew that
i wouldn't want to be vulnerable right
because i want to be hurt right and then
with dez i actually
he called me out because we like started
talking and i like posted something with
another guy and he was like by the way
if you want to play games like that's
cool i just like i'm too old for that i
couldn't agree more and i literally my
tail went between my legs and i never do
this normally i'd be like okay go [ __ ]
yourself and i was like i was like i'm
so sorry that's not me that's not who i
want to be in this yeah and from that
moment on it he just kind of knew what
he wants and he's kind of like three
quarters baked like he's learned from a
lot of his accessories
because we don't we're working women we
don't have time to teach a man no we
certainly don't but i do have somehow
found time to teach a man how to pick
his clothes up off the [ __ ] door and
put them in the [ __ ] hamper
like
there's two kind of relationships i
think where you literally grow together
and you evolve into this beautiful tree
or whatever metaphor you want to use or
two people who have kind of been
independent and happen to enjoy each
other right so like
and i've recently come to this
realization because i was always like
yeah i got married young like everyone
should do it but honestly the older i
get i realized like no one should get
married young like because when i think
about like the gal who got married at
well the girl the gal who got engaged
when she was 21 i mean i so don't know
that girl like we are so different and
it's very possible i could have turned
into a person that ben hated or ben
could have grown up into a person that i
[ __ ] hated and and that's why divorce
is okay right it's totally okay but
that's why it's like think think it
through think about it well it's like
trends yeah like he's trending when
you're 20 but is he chooky by the time
you're 29 right so there's a lot to
think about when it comes to your
potential suitor and i'm so happy that
you found someone and i do it does make
me really thank you it does make me
realize that when you're
a celebrity it's almost like why why are
we rushing for like the paper and stuff
it's like let yourself have a lot of
money exactly exactly but i was i don't
let people know i was very single and
quarantined with four cats living with
my parents in shelter island when i was
29. you have four cats my mom does okay
because like but i do have one her
name's butter but you have a cat i have
a cat um
should i leave so thank you so much
we'll finish the show without you
i do say that cats have terrible pr
no cats are just terrible period
i
mean to say in front like you obviously
love your cat but like i you're like
your cat should be thrown out of a
window but i love her i don't support
animals you have a king character
yeah i love those dogs because i think
they're like cats
girl get a grip like
no like aesthetically how they're like
that size and then you like pet them and
they're just like lap ladies it was
really important to me and i would
appreciate if you didn't just like
slander his name literally right in
front of my face
okay this is i actually say it's on
stage sometimes but like dogs have the
puppy bowl marley and me air bud like
that's yeah cat's got nothing no
cats have the cats movie
that ruined lives yeah but you know what
else you have that like kind of trumps
everything
taylor swift
yeah that's like kind of the hardest
part for me honestly about being a
swifty
is knowing that like honestly if taylor
invited me over to her house and there
were cats there like i wouldn't go
okay i i think about that i'm like when
i it's not an if it's like when i become
friends with taylor swift how are we
going to get around the cats i feel like
i'm a cat missionary and like we're
going to have a riot right now but
if you've never had your own cat you've
never understood the relationship with
it that's true and i'm not going to
force you i'm not gonna kiss you
i wanna king charles even though i think
they think they're better than me they
are
they're better than me too by the way
like i see them down the street and
they're like ill no no literally theo
walks down the street he's like he's
literally anna delvey so basic
so poor
vip like i'm embarrassed for you
but i'm obsessed with you also
do you get any um competitiveness with
your king charles dogs in the family no
so like the thing is is that theo's a
king and like you know he was the first
to ever do it and bruno and magnolia are
amazing and i literally have so much
love in my heart for them like no one's
ever gonna be theo yeah he's og but
i am going to manifest like a private
jet moment with my cat
in a backpack as taylor tell us no and
you know what that i 100 but also like
has anyone checked on the cat like did
was it kind of okay with that yeah by
the way those backpacks that like people
throw their cats in are a little weird
i see them all the time it's
or like if you start walking your cat i
think leashes
are hilarious especially just on
children and cats
no and like by the way i'm not like a
cat expert like maybe cats like they
don't need oxygen like i don't
understand those backpacks cats are just
evil beings that don't need air right
like what the [ __ ] yeah so we straight
far away from rihanna
um i go sure we'll do the fast five but
i don't think that the general consensus
is no she's not engaged she's not
engaged she's rich okay next story is
about two of my literal favorite people
in hollywood
keith urban recalls the moment his wife
nicole kidman staged an intervention
after a boozy bender prior to his rehab
stint in 2006. allegedly he said i went
went off the rails so keith urban is
recalling this moment he did um
oh he has an ex an extract from his book
um
written by someone else but it's a book
about keith urban um and it was
published in the daily telegraph so he
checked himself into the betty ford
center
sheik
um in october 2006 and keith told
rolling stone that in 2016
he would have understood if nicole chose
to leave him um that year because they
had only gotten married that year um he
said i was very very blessed to have
nicole call an intervention on me
because the implosion
um because it could have caused the
implosion of my marriage i don't know
why i can't [ __ ] talk today sorry so
he reflected um
the daily mail writes like not in
english i'm sorry
it's not the point the voice there's
like so much words the voice australia
coach like why
they're like trying to fill a word count
also reflected on the intervention with
oprah winfrey admitting to the famed
talk show host that he went off the
rails and needed help and a new
direction in his life nicole who was in
rome for work at the time of his boozy
bender
flew back to the states and rounded up
his friends to stage an intervention
have you ever had an intervention
um
is like just like crying with your
family all the time an intervention no
it's like your family telling you
everything that's wrong with you i've so
yes
i also think this is so funny that
nicole was like off the rails i was with
tom cruise this is adorable right right
no and think about it like how bad must
uh keith ehrman have been for like
because nicole you're right nicole kim
has seen some [ __ ] like scientology her
kids like shunned her because crazy yes
how bad was keith urban for her to have
like really been concerned because that
woman has she's seen things well i do
think it's hard when you want to be with
a rock star who's like fun and cool and
it's a thin line with addiction because
you will choose your addiction over your
relationships but i love that she fought
for him me too i love these two and i i
feel like she's heroic in the way that
she's like i know i'm making millions of
dollars in this in rome for this movie
but like my man is like having a moment
at the moment
making it about him
i like
much like paige and craig like
the bullets i would take they're like
one of my top five celebrity couples
first of all because i'm such a country
music girly i'm a press on nelly girl
yeah i'm also a country music early and
i do you think i beat that joke like
dead no no okay because i mean it'll die
but it'll come back okay okay cause like
you stopped laughing so like i didn't
know if it was like funny anymore
um
like i love these two i love country
music i love her work have you ever seen
stepford wives yes
such a good movie so good one of her
underrated ones yes because she
naturally kind of looks like a wax
figure it was like the easiest world
she's ever played she didn't even do
hair and makeup
but i also i do i think we love them
because they're like partnerships
and institutions like karen hugher would
say and yeah
and she's a and he's a short king yes
which we're going to get to because
apparently it's short king spring and i
need to get your take on that
he is a short king by the way not only
is he a short king she's really tall
she's really tall but she also was with
tom cruise like maybe she's got a thing
for short guys they walk so zendaya and
tom holland could run yeah mm-hmm is it
zendaya isn't daya i believe it's andrea
okay i apologize to everyone for that
moment um you're right like he is the
short king of our generation he's
honestly like and he's australian and
sings country like yeah no
keith urban is to me an anomaly but
there is like a weird country music
scene in australia and new zealand like
kelsey ballerini's husband morgan evans
is an amazing country singer from
australia too
the twist she loves country you you
didn't even go to like a southern
college or anything no i'm literally
jewish from long island yeah literally
born and raised in new york and long
island
i did go to university of wisconsin and
i was forced to go to um a
shoot what was it it was like an old
school country concert but i really
liked it i do love
chicken fried zach brown band jack brown
band and um
yes love that song
the twist she's gorgeous
did you watch that special yes
cat cullen we stan you it was
one of the best specials i've seen in a
while so different
the singing like i was mesmerized uh
first of all her voice is incredible
yeah it's a new netflix special her name
is katherine cohen it i'd seen clips for
it all over like netflix and tiktok um
and instagram
it was like
unbelievable i loved it and what's great
about it is that
this special was ready to go
she was gonna film it and then
quarantine hit so these are jokes that
like she's had right and had to like
keep them and get and they excited and
they aged great and i do think
stand up can be so much more just
spinning jokes and her overall persona
is so fun so over the top over the top
fabric psychotic like i loved it you
have to have her on no i know by the way
i literally just like was introduced to
her yeah and i'm obsessed please come on
the show like please cause i mean you
guys are like kindred spirits like not
like we are we're gorgeous
like i'm not trying to get jealous of
kat cohen in your friendship but like
the fact that you both sing and you're
both gorgeous no i agree like i was very
much like feeling like this like i was
feeling inspired yeah like it was
incredible the original songs were so
good yeah what are you running from like
so good i loved it i hope everyone
watches and loving attention yeah she's
just so self-aware while being not
self-aware so honest too yes yeah like
it was just it was amazing i highly
recommend it if you're looking also chin
is out on netflix this weekend so we
love keith urban we love keith urban and
just like wanting i didn't even know he
was sober it's crazy how i could be like
his number one fan and i didn't even
know that i do love a sober relationship
because actually dez is sober oh really
he's been sober since he's 19. important
thing that no one talked about which was
like kind of crucial to like our
experience yeah
of course because it could be super
toxic in that house if you're sober but
he he was so great he hung out with
everyone the whole time we just went to
bed like a little earlier so interesting
so he's been sober since 19 because he
realized like for his career because
comedy it's so easy to just get
plastered every night by the way a
hundred percent like when i first
started doing comedy i used to like take
a shot before every show and i'd be like
yeah like we're so crazy we're working
and then like somebody like in you know
those like random like old school comedy
clubs in like north carolina yeah those
people like scene [ __ ] yes
she the manager there made this like
really offhand remark like i don't think
they meant anything about it but did
they give you an intervention no
no maybe
they were just like yeah that's how you
know everyone becomes alcoholic string
before the show i'm like oh my god [ __ ]
you're right if i'm doing 100 shows a
year and i need to take a shot before
every show and then maybe like one after
like that's 200 shots and i immediately
don't drink some when i go out
afterwards like i will drink but i do
not drink before a lot of the time you
don't really want to go out afterwards
because you're like i'm exhausted
sweating sweating in the back of my neck
like no disgusting and you just you were
so on you're like can we turn off for a
second
i don't drink on the road either really
and people hate it because i'm like i'm
fun i'm crazy and then they want to hang
out with you after and i'm not like this
is it's not that's an act but like i
just prefer i'm much more witty sober
too of course when i'm drunk i'm just
like look at my ass you know i do like
like tick-tock dances like it's not
funny
it goes like we're always teetering
annoying i go full annoying do you
perform have you have you performed
drunk before i perform drunk sometimes
like because during the week i'll have
like four sets and i'll over the course
of four hours and you're just hanging
with comics you start drinking yeah
that's when i realized i have fun on
stage but other people not so much yeah
because i'm like this is hilarious and
they're like no it's not you don't even
finish the joke and you're like that is
my favorite joke um but i do think
comics are either like
party party party or completely sober
yeah no you're 100 right but we love a
sober king because
think of the lack of fighting because
we're not drinking like think of the
lack of bad breath like think of a lack
of a lot of things and then like do i
hate that he pops up in the morning at
seven am ready to go like is that his
biggest toxic trait yeah that causes
fights absolutely yeah because this is
still the middle of the night for me
right um but i'd rather that than us
like fighting fighting over drunk stuff
so what's that like i honestly i i don't
know if i
could imagine myself in a relationship
with someone who's sober just because
drinking is like such a cornerstone and
that's that's a meat problem like spirit
society.com that's like a cornerstone of
my life and that's probably a problem
but like what's that like for you well
like i like that you your relationship
started young because it probably wasn't
based on partying no not at all and i
think for those people like you know
they joke like do you like him or is he
just tall do you like him or is he just
like good at partying with you right
like you're both just wasting like you
think it's fun yeah and then is the
dopamine of like being out and like
having you know a drake song come on and
like you're kind of buzzed like that's
not love yeah and i do think that
alcohol
sometimes people use it as an excuse
like oh he's just mean because he's
drunk but it's like that's also the
truth coming out of things and it just
enables people to fight more so
me also i'm more of an eater
girl preach and he's really good at
eating with me like i'll look at him he
looks at me we're we're doing that
through the foundations have a beautiful
relationship yes and i do think it's
those that's our like naughty night i
love that for you um okay well i'm
learning so much i had no idea about any
of this we're having fun today yes we're
having fun and our fun is brought to you
by omaze
if you've ever dreamed of having the
chance to win awesome prizes like doing
karaoke with charlize theron
winning a tesla going to space then
you've got to check out omaze the new
way to give back to charity and have fun
doing it here's how omaze works you
enter for the chance to win something
amazing and at the same time you can
donate to support great causes it's a
fun and easy way for nonprofits to raise
money and for you to win big prizes like
a multi-million dollar house in lake
tahoe so go to omaze.com toast select
the lake tahoe dream house or whatever
you want to win the deadline to enter is
april 14th so hurry for your chance to
win if you missed the deadline don't
worry omaze has tons of other exciting
prizes and experiences to choose from
through your donations omaze has raised
more than 150 million dollars to support
over 350 non-profits around the world
everyone deserves a chance to live their
dreams and with oma's extraordinary
prizes are within reach hurry and enter
today for your chance to win the lake
tahoe dream house or other life-changing
prizes and experiences at omaze.com
toast that's o-m-a-z-e dot com toast
plus you can receive an extra 20 entries
when you enter code toast 20. that's
toast 2-0 no purchase necessary to enter
a win visit omaze.com toast for official
rules all right next up some some more
wedding news
robin thinks beyonce april of geary says
she won't sign a prenup she went on
instagram live and no nine instagram
live instagram q a and someone was like
does robin want a prenup before marriage
which is the type of question you ignore
[Laughter]
um but she did not she said i don't know
but i'm not signing one she then
explained he's not marrying anyone else
after me how do you go from like the
baddest [ __ ] on the planet where do you
go from there trash i love that for her
by the way um
and yeah she's not signing a pre-nap i
honestly feel like these two have been
engaged for so long and i kind of hate
robin thicke
who doesn't he's like extremely good
looking and wonderful velvety thick
voice but i just remember like the way
he treated paula patton like i will
never forgive and i'm just like i i
can't really express how little i care
about these two my like senses of like
people who are trying too hard with
their relationship is tingling so hard
with that radar is going also like who
are you calling trash like leave them in
the women
like leave the future person he's
leaving you right for like that's like
even manifesting like she manifested
wrong there yeah also this man cheated
on his ex
like how can we not see what's going on
like maybe this is a love match but that
doesn't mean he won't cheat on you or
that he won't like this is hollywood
yeah also no matter how comfortable you
are in a relationship i would never be
like he will never leave me well i joke
all the time like we're getting married
on friday the 13th oh wow like if we're
going to get divorced
it's not because the 13th like i'm doing
it i'm committing nobody but i will use
that as an excuse if we do
even the most perfect marriage is like i
could see ben leaving me like i'm the
worst like no i'm not out here being
like i know for sure that my
relationship is going to work forever
i'm like we're all trying to progress
every day of course and i do think
calling
she didn't call anyone trash from like
how dare you call that person trapped no
like she's like who's he gonna leave me
for trash but also like love the
confidence we love the confidence but
like who is trash when he leaves you
he's trash right if he cheats you on
someone let's get mad at him and like
you should be getting paid for your time
i don't i don't want to bring up
this traumatic moment but do you
remember when he took a photo with that
girl and the mirror was behind them and
you saw him squeezing her ass no
what girl she was a fan
and it was while he was with paula so
like i just whenever people say his name
i visualize that photo no n m rada like
spoke about her experience on that music
video set as being like extremely toxic
like yeah i like i literally hate this
man but you're right they could be a
love match because they're toxic in the
right ways both of them and maybe he's
evolved because i'm all about people
evolving yeah i don't think like when
you're that set in your ways like he's
like a cuban junior to me like i don't
think you're changing your ways at the
ripe old age of 50 after grabbing
women's asses for years and getting away
with it what are you gonna leave me for
also like
i hate the idea even on tic tac where
people are like
um
she's like calling other girls trash
that you guys been with i feel like
the way you get confidence also in
yourself as a girl is not being like oh
there's a ranking system of like trash
to amazing it's more like who has the
best compatibility with the other person
that's actually really true you know
that's a really mature well i think i've
the point of your 20s for me was like
dating the guys who like disney taught
me to be attracted to right like the
narcissistic charming hot gaston guys
exactly be with gaston realize it makes
you absolutely miserable and find the
person who's right for you not right for
society even though i do have to say
just as it pertains to gaston we have a
big theory here at the morning toast
that gaston was actually like a really
nice guy
um he was a war hero he was extremely
into belle
and the beast like you know kidnapped
her and like kind of justice for gaston
like all he did was really like want
belle and maybe his methods were a
little crazy but like haven't we all
done crazy things for love i do also
feel like they wanted a villain
right and like he did like get drunk and
sing really loudly sometimes yeah but so
do i
exactly
and they wanted you to like root against
him but i do think in beauty and the
beast i could go on about beauty and the
beast
is that no one wanted to [ __ ] the guy he
turned into he was a fratty lacrosse
dweeb who we hated the beast at least
was like six four and pulled off and he
had a house he was a homeowner had alice
had a library and read that right
that's super hot also i do have to say
like if we had to choose a villain of
the film it's obviously belle's dad
he is the worst character he's a [ __ ]
like you've made this trip back and
forth to the farm or wherever he was
going a thousand times and you get
[ __ ] lost like get a map [ __ ] write
down directions he was like the village
freak and you know what like he was the
villain at least
was good looking fun to look at at least
on like and and jackie once shared with
me like somebody actually put together
like this whole powerpoint presentation
of like why gaston is an actual hero
and um and if you look at like the
socioeconomic
like timing of the film it's like post
it's pre-revolutionary
france and actually in a few years like
there is this revolution and people like
the beasts like they are overthrown by
people like gaston so in a few years
time like gaston is in power yes in this
you know so it would have been a
long-term investment for her exactly
high yielding and people will say the
beast is super controlling and he is but
i do respect her for being like
i'm gonna stay here and have gay
utensils get me food the whole time and
do the dishes because this is
comfortable for me no and it's like my
napkins are gonna dance their way onto
my lap
and back at home i have to deal with my
crazy ass dad see you know what i kind
of like it here even though i live in a
cell
it does like go back that movie just is
your therapy session be like
it's let's stop blaming everyone it's
your dad
right
like who do you identify with in the
film because personally i'm a lumiere
like
no doubt like i dazzle i entertain like
i am a lumiere
oh my god who are you
i feel like i'm like
i'm the beast obviously
correct has a man called me that before
absolutely
but i do feel you know like my biggest
war is with myself and i feel like the
beast
you know is just trying his best but
like has some mental issues yeah no i
agree that does sound like yeah
okay so april of geary is not signing a
prenup we don't care um all right
according to the new york post
actually according to tick tock it's
officially short king spring and these
fellas are soaring after years of
getting the short end of the stick tick
tock has declared that these little guys
deserve a royal treatment short kings is
the new wave sorry to all y'all giraffes
one fellow celebrated on tick tock with
the dance it's being dubbed short king
spring on social media single new
yorkers are looking for love
less than five eight and a group who
have been notoriously short-sighted on
dating apps are having their time
because anyone taller than 511 no longer
qualifies one female with a tall order
announced but another one declared that
she loves the shorties and the tick tock
tag short king has more than 330 million
views and some users are calling the
increase in interest the short king
spring the trend is perhaps inspired by
tom holland and zendaya whose height
difference is 5 8 and she's 5 11 and it
doesn't deter their romance but it
rather breaks the internet so
speak i do
think that it's more about energy than
height oh my god you're like so light
what's the most value
cause like do i have jokes about short
kings absolutely do i say that if we're
on the disney motive um snow white the
fact that she was stuck with seven short
men was truly scary for her but i do
think i love a short man with like
bigger energy they have to try harder
for sure because then there's short men
who have like the napoleon energy oh i'm
so toxic i don't want to get political
but putin and
i'm not trying to make this cnn but
and tnn but same same thing yes tnn so i
think that
it's i love that we're like giving
confidence to men about their physical
bodies but like it just seems like
like what we're trying so hard like to
make men feel comfortable about their
bodies i don't know it just sits wrong
with me and where's the energy for the
female body positivity where is that and
yeah men
this is toxic but i just don't think men
need a campaign to feel comfortable in
their own bodies in a world where like
they're valued for they've always been
valued for their personality and
everything else and they're they like
they just have to be rich like shut up
okay can i tell you why this story gives
me like a pit in my stomach because it
reminds me of like the real first or
maybe second time i ever got like in
like trouble on the internet before
obviously like the major downfall of
2018. um in like 2016 when i was in
college and i was like writing these
blog posts i was just like trying to
find things to like write about that was
like funny
and i just like had this thought one day
how like it just sucks to be a short guy
so i wrote this like hella offensive
blog post about how like
as a guy like if you're ugly but like
you're rich um or like really good at
sports like that just makes you hotter
um but the one thing like you really can
never get around is being short like it
just [ __ ] sucks like you're always
gonna be a tour guide no matter how rich
no matter how smart no matter how funny
no matter how athletic you are the short
king and
someone it was my blog back in the day
was like not popular like i can't stress
that enough
but somebody like found it and posted it
on the subreddit like first it was
called our shorts like read it for short
people and these short guys were just
like lamenting about being short and
somebody posted a link to my blog post
and i was like coming back from class in
college and like i opened my computer
and i was like checking my google
analytics and i had like seven thousand
hits on my blog i was like holy [ __ ]
like finally i'm not shadow bands i've
gone viral and i started reading the
comments and i was literally getting
death threats like literally like kill
yourself like and i was like you could
trace on google analytics like where the
traffic is coming from and it was like
reddit i'm like what is that i never
heard of it and i saw this like is this
for ugly men they literally like they
tore me apart so i can really no i can
provide no further comment
because because of my trauma
so can you continue
i am notorious though for like
i know at [ __ ] i was writing a ton of
like do i like him rosie just tall right
i've come to the conclusion that just
because he's tall does not mean he's a
good person have i stayed like the
amount of inches a guy is above six feet
is the amount of months i stay with him
after discovering he's a trash bag right
so like the tallness has hurt me i also
have gone from dating like six ten guys
to like a five seven dude how tall are
you i'm five seven and how tall is dez
there's a 6-3 and people don't talk
about it enough yeah so actually ben is
six one ben is massive and i remember
telling him that when i met him i go
sturdy yeah the thing is like i do feel
a little guilty because i'm five feet
zero yep and i do feel like you know i
am built
like evolution wise like i should have
been matched up with one of the short
kings who's like five seven or five
eight cause that's still like way taller
than me are you attracted to a five
seven king um i'm not attracted to
anyone but my husband and my dog that
was a test and she passed it but you i
can like put you in my pocket like
you're a literal keychain
frail i i am taller i also like in my
head wanted like a division one athlete
child so i didn't have to pay for
college but that was me just like
planning too hard des also in photos
looks smaller than he is and people were
like comparing him to certain short
kings that i will not say and i was like
but he is 6'3 and that is a huge reason
why i was attracted to me in the
beginning i think attraction is
important and we could be attracted to
tallman short man whatever but it's
about being
a kind good person yeah work on that
yeah i guess i think keith urban's
really hot so yeah i'm attracted to
short men there's some short men where
you're like
he
[ __ ] good well i was just going to say
i feel like short men are like they work
harder like no they're just like into
freaky [ __ ] you know
well like sometimes their head is just
like at my [ __ ] so they can just like
go for it
no but i also think some tall men
have that like tall man privilege where
they didn't have to try no and they were
like blah
yeah like their personalities like they
never had to establish a personality
because they'd always get attention they
people laughed at their jokes when they
weren't funny just because you're tall
right it's something we said about short
man that was like i'm gonna learn how to
make a woman orgasm that i think some
tall men
missed that just so they can become
competitive like get in the game yeah so
i do think there's pluses that we're not
seeing here it's like that episode of 30
rock where liz lemon starts to date like
jon hamm's character and it's like she's
dating someone so much more like
stunning than her and she didn't realize
like these beautiful people like they
live in a different universe where like
you go to a
restaurant you just like get a table you
don't like the bar for 45 minutes and
she's like loving like the riding the
coattails of like this privilege um and
it's so true
i've dated
around the spectrum like i went from
dating like a mascot in college to
dating models because i thought it was
like cool and it made me feel better
about myself like
but referring to luke as models
sometimes okay but like i dated because
i've never seen a model in anything i
did a model where like he would say
jokes to people that were so
bad and stupid like worse than dad jokes
and people would be like
oh god and i'm like this is why he is
the way he is so low the bar is so low
and you do see that they're living in
their own reality and that's why i think
super hot people end up with super hot
people because they can like live that
[ __ ] together yeah where like i happen
with me in bed
exactly so you guys that's when you got
shadow band you were like this is crazy
yeah we live in that beautiful people
world we're like [ __ ] like that just
doesn't happen to us
for sure like you go like this and
uber's just come you don't even use that
yeah no i just
i just do a little of this
um well we have one more story and i'm
very excited to chat with you about it
and so is legacy box because the fifth
and final story is brought to you by
legacy box the simple affordable we've
thought of everything solution for
digitally preserving your past send in
your legacy box filled with old vhs
tapes camcorder tapes film reels and
pictures and get back digital copies
that can be easily enjoyed shared and
organized so declutter by digitizing
your aging video tapes if you've just
got like vhs cassettes stacked up in
storage units that you really want to be
able to watch share with your family
legacy box is the thing that you need
they make it so easy to digitize all of
your old videos
they send you a kit that's super easy
and safe um
each kit includes everything that you
need to safely pack and send your
recorded moments including safety
stickers legacy boxes team of 200
trained technicians processed 19
different media types from vhs to super
8 film by hand right here in the usa
they have been trusted in the industry
in profession professionally digitizing
families memories for over a decade
their exclusive barcoded online tracking
system gets you um up to eight up to 12
emailed updates along the way so you
always know what the process is all of
your
vhs and cassettes are in safe hands with
legacy box get started preserving your
past today go to legacy box dot com
slash toast to get an incredible 50 off
you guys are always dming me like what's
the company that does it's a great gift
for anyone in your life you can buy it
now and use it later but here it is it's
legacybox.com
toast buy today and take advantage of
the exclusive offer and send it when
you're ready
legacybox.comtoast to save 50 off while
supplies last all right our final story
is a little tech news because we're just
like two tech influencer girlies um
instagram's new chronological mode is
exactly what a feed should be according
to the verge so they announced on
wednesday
that they're adding two new modes that
change how the main feed works bringing
back the much awaited reverse
chronological view the company calls the
two new modes the following modes and
the favorite modes and say that they're
designed to give you more choice and
control over what you see while using
the app
and that is let you avoid things like
suggested post and algorithm sorting so
the description for the following feed
is truly something to behold they say
see the latest posts from accounts that
you follow in the order that they were
posted
um and then you could also have
favorites where you choose like your
favorite creators and you only see that
feed i'm not crazy about having two
different ways like just choose yeah
like because don't make us use our brain
any more than we have to we're on
instagram for a reason like we're
obviously bored
yeah cause for some reason we like took
a break from tick tock right
i
am having problems with instagram i just
don't feel inspired by it i mean
obviously follow me my page is amazing
but like i can't
i i'm bored i feel like they've hit a
wall compared to tick-tock is doing so
well and this is like making me even
more nervous because as a creator it's
like you just feel like instagram just
has like a couple people being like
let's twist this around
and they're like post reels reels aren't
working no like the way that the
chokehold instagram executives have like
on our bills being paid is so crazy
you're 100 right and i feel like why
people love tick tock is because tick
tock is so
like they back the creators they pay
creators which is insane like the way
youtube does the way instagram should so
of course creators are flocking to tick
tock they pay creators they make it so
easy for creators to like be creative
and and you and make content and and
just have an easy experience on the app
the algorithm is so good on tick tock
where i swear everyone who follows me is
just like me and the stuff i'm seeing
like they're diagnosing me with ibs like
yeah they know tic tac knows me more
than me
instagram i feel like i'm walking into
like what kind of like a social
influencer event that doesn't really
want me there that's such a good analogy
and you're kind of like well that's cool
but like do i even want to be here and i
do think with social media with
everything not to bla
but
if you feel bad about yourself after
using it stop yeah so that's why i think
we're naturally going to tic toc where
it's stuff we want to see that's
actually so [ __ ] true like i don't
feel bad about myself like i watched
this woman yesterday right before bed
i've ended up on like i think korean
tick tock um where she like
has this big bowl of like soup and
there's like 15 hard-boiled eggs in
there she eats each egg in like one bite
and she just like with chopsticks which
is crazy to pick up a hard-boiled egg
with chopsticks she just takes each egg
and like chews it and she's like this
tiny little woman i'm like how are you
eating so many eggs and it was really
like probably the best video i've seen
in a while i need to see that
immediately next time i find one i'll
send it to you because i envision it
just being
yeah no and it's like so satisfying she
doesn't even chew you know it's gorgeous
i love that for her i know and she's
like eating so much and she's still so
tiny which is like my dream
that's like a beautiful and joyful
moment i know and even besides what
you're consuming on instagram the stress
of being like how do i make this photo
dump like look interesting i know and so
now we don't even post one we have to
post like 10 i know and and what do you
think about the new generation of like
influencers creators becoming famous on
tik tok
i think that it's a great launching pad
as everything is as you and i know you
know veterans um get old you decide what
you
want for your career long term i think
some tick tockers are popping off for
like very specific things i know and
some tick talkers i think is funny they
don't plan to pop off and they're like
shoot i don't want to be
making different iced coffee for the
rest of my life so some people i think
like addison ray are going to be capable
of doing a lot of things and it just
depends on kind of your vision you know
i like every time i run into like a tick
talker who i meet i'm like i always feel
like compelled to give them advice which
i don't know if they want to hear yeah
but like it just makes me nervous that
like all these young kids they're having
so much success and they're quitting
their jobs and they're getting brand
deals and i just don't it makes me
nervous when influencers
are gonna you know plan the rest of
their life to live off of brand deals
because brand deals are great and
they're wonderful
and there's a lot of money in there but
it's not stable income and you know
you're really hot when you launch and
then as anything happens as you know
being on being on the internet you have
high moments you have low moments you're
hot you're cold you're irrelevant you're
relevant so it just makes me nervous
when like you know they're relying on
all these brands and i just like every
time i meet them like you have any
advice i'm like yes like write a book
start a podcast start a youtube channel
start like a home base something go on
tour like do something that
you can make money from steadily that
doesn't require a brand deal because
like it just makes me nervous and
doesn't require that if god forbid tick
tock was taken over by aliens exactly
you can exist because we have multiple
sources of streams of income it's so
it's it sounds so lame but it's so
important and i do think it's cool that
people are popping off but it's also
like find something that you're
passionate about that you want to do for
long term yeah and i do think it's cool
seeing how but then some tick talkers
their fans are incredible and will show
up to live shows and that's when you
know that you've successfully
transitioned from being like a content
creator to being like
a celebrity yeah and then there's some
tick-tockers who have millions of
followers but they don't have that like
connection with their audience they
launch merch and they sell 30 shirts
exactly that's why it's so important
like me i'm always talking about this
and i talk about it a lot in the book
like you can have i would rather have
a hundred thousand like dead ass devoted
followers than two million irrelevant
people who like just like my content but
like will never you know want to learn
more about me never want to listen to my
podcast watch a youtube video like
there's so much value at that on the in
that front it's about quality not
quantity for sure and i do think my
experience when starting reality tv was
very like you're going to be you know
shown in a lot of different situations
and some people are going to like
understand you and want to learn more
about you and some people won't and
that's totally fine it's like in
stand-up comedy
instead of trying to fight the one
person with their hand like this
give it to your girlies
give it to them and then grow from there
and i do think some were similar in a
way where i think our followers are very
similar to us and get us yeah and
they're in similar stages of their life
exactly and we're growing with them so
anyway the tick tock the scary thing is
like some of these people are literally
16. i know and i feel like i just get
nervous so like if there's any up and
coming tick talkers like just take my
advice like don't just like it's all
really hot right now but that [ __ ] dies
down so quickly like another app comes
and so make all the money that you can
right now but also plan for the future
like if you really want to get into like
the business of influencing like start
other revenue streams
um no i just want to switch gears
because we are done with the stories but
there's one more thing before i let you
go that i kind of want to ask you about
um one of like
like you have been through a reunion
and i just want to know like the like
what's that like like how many hours is
it
like
six to eight i mean ours are not
housewives
like i do think andy is like
your show's cute
like andy i don't think he watched our
show at all he like saw a clip but he
was like highlight reel highlight reel
um but it's fun to like get dressed up
and stuff and and where was it in the
city somewhere in the city my first one
was over zoom
which was so funny because paige and i
texted the entire time and then like you
think you you can cut in and then you
can't right you're just like and then oh
god
cause you know like timing is so
important to say something and it takes
there's like a couple second audio lag
so like no one hears you the zoom was
wild or someone would just be going on
and on and like no one could cut them
off because like they're in their moment
and then someone's like headphones are
breaking so it's hard to get the
momentum
um my last rune i
i did not watch it and i did black out
and i cried the whole time so i don't i
did watch it and i just want to let you
know i thought like you were treated
really unfairly thank you like i thought
the editing was really bad for you but
you like also did yourself in a favor
but then like okay it wasn't that
serious like everyone's being so mean at
the reunion like calm the [ __ ] down it's
not that serious no i know i mean i'm
all about
entertaining stirring the pot having fun
showing up and i did not anticipate
what was happening because yeah
you know it's not that serious and also
like i've been in the game for four
years and i like really did care about
all those people of course and you're
still friendly with a lot of them yes
okay good would you ever do reality tv
again
um
i think knowing how the sausage is made
it's a little hard and i do think i
bring
more value
being like purely myself and not a
character
but
who knows in the future like when i
might need money yeah of course oh my
god never count out the countess no but
i mean like overall like there could be
fun situations my favorite show is
pitbulls and parolees what the [ __ ] is
that oh my god it's in louisiana and
it's this lady who works with paroles
like people who are out of jail
and rescuing pit bulls
and they give the pit bulls to people
and they find matches and these people
it's about like giving people a second
chance and like
i want to be in an animal show
speaking of
weird [ __ ] we watch do you watch mrs
duchy on tik tok
no oh
what
okay mrs duchess wait is she a dog no
she's a lady okay it sounds like one of
those dogs who dresses up but she's a
lady who goes live on tik tok every
single night for three hours and she
makes tumblers like out of resin yes i
know who she is and like she's so cute
like people order the the tumblers and
she's on the phone with them like
choosing the colors and she's like oh my
god this is gorgeous but they like
change their minds with this drama
there's always drama like it's so
exciting she goes and like i don't even
follow her but i know she comes up on my
for you page every single night because
she goes live from 8 11 and i just
wanted to see if you were like a miss
duchy girl i am a miss such a girl i
didn't know her name i just knew the
energy she gave me and she misses
dutchies mrs dutchy i apologize
but that is like a version of asmr and i
love that you brought her up because
she's older in her life
um she's having so much success a wise
queen and for people who see like
tick-tockers blowing up um buying four
houses in la i like to think of people
as popcorn actually mike fenia comic
said this example that like we're all
under the same temperature but we pop at
different times oh i love that and i do
think that's important for people to
know yeah because if you're not like
hitting
where you thought you'd hit at a certain
age like you're just not popping yet
it's fine and also when i was 16 i
probably wasn't going to be putting my
best foot forward out in the
entertainment industry right just
probably for the best that you didn't
pop at 16. exactly i didn't put my [ __ ]
at 16. um well hannah it has been an
absolute pleasure a glory having you
thank you so much for being here thank
you so much for having me i'm truly a
fan and this has been a career like
check mark yes where can people find
tickets to your stand up and all your
content so i'm going to be in denver and
austin go to hannah bernadotte are you
going to austin the 20th to the 23rd of
april sorry sorry i'm going thursday
um now i'm paranoid about getting shadow
bands so definitely follow me at being
burns instagram being burns and listen
to paige and i on giggly squad yes it's
so cute and if you like mental health
comedy stuff burning in hell b-e-r-n-e-i
whatever you're such a good last name
for like pun
yes i have like no puns and also we
discovered
oh well yeah we discovered your coffee
shtick when you were in it when we were
like this girl just hates coffee but you
were using it to just [ __ ] on every
single every person's order and it was
amazing because we were like how is she
gonna gag in this i have to say like
every time you talk about me on giggly
squad i do get a dm about it and i
listen to the entire episode waiting for
like my mom but that makes me happy
because sometimes like you'll mention
someone's name and everyone's like they
talk [ __ ] about you but we literally
were like she's iconic no so i get like
a messages all the time like you were
mentioned on ex podcast and like i try
and gauge like from the person sending
the message like is this a positive or a
negative because for me it really could
go either way yeah um and i figured you
guys were possible we were also online
sleuths like you where we were sending
stuff to each other from you and then we
were like well we have to tell
the girlies what's going on the girlies
thank you so much for being here come
see hannah on tour she's so funny listen
to her podcast follow her on instagram
follow her on tick tock also follow me
on twitter
um and thank you so much for being here
thank you guys for listening to the
morning toast i hope you had a great
week sorry about all the drama with the
stomach flu i am feeling better thank
you so much everyone who reached out
we're back next week with a monday
tuesday wednesday episode the schedule
will be up on wednesday and then
thursday friday saturday sunday i'm in
dallas houston and austin so come see me
love you guys so much thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we deliver
the best stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please [ __ ] subscribe already okay
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and we're
podcasting we found some spotify items
it's your public radio i have radio cast
box all the places so if you listen to
podcast find out more until sleep five
star review better beautiful sunny and
smart we are thank you hannah thank you
toasters have a great weekend we'll see
you on monday bye
oh my god
you